[Music]  there's security camera footage of a  fedex employee  uh delivering a plasma television  and uh yeah this is the actual footage  this is real of a real fedex delivery  man delivering a plasma tv and it's  spreading throughout the internet and  people are really horrified by what they  see take a look at this footage  yeah that's what he does he chucks it  it's a plasma screen television okay  well people got upset about this and  then i just started surfing online and  apparently this is not an isolated  incident this is a disturbing trend  at fedex check out this other security  footage i just found  [Applause]  [Laughter]  [Applause]  you